it is good to see you how are you i'm
great how are you
i'm doing very well listen be a triangle
if you know your math
and if you know your architecture then
you know what that's all about you know
what that triangle is all about you got
to be strong you got it's the strongest
thing right you know all all throughout
my
my educational life i used to wonder why
my teachers were so adamant on teaching
me about the triangle and i thought i
was never going to use this in my life
and now here i am
they showed me
that's it it's one of those things where
you're like why am i gonna need to know
this guy oh you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna book after it that's fan it's
the only way to use the knowledge
okay so
we talked about uh how to be a boss ages
ago when when it came out
and one thing that i always love about
what you do
is your
transparency your vulnerability and
you're writing from and performing from
exactly where you are in the moment so
where does this one come from
yeah that's a great question this book
came from um
a place i found myself in during the
pandemic and i think a lot of people can
relate to this that that was rough for
everyone in different ways but i didn't
anticipate it being so bleak in the
sense that i really learned about myself
that i actually don't value
myself at all aside from via work i
actually only see my value through when
i'm really really busy and the things
that keep me busy and the relationships
that keep me busy when a lot of that
stopped i felt like i had no purpose and
i felt like i had no value that really
bothered me and i realized that's
because i don't actually have
a strong foundation for my life i don't
know who i am without those things i
don't know what i want to do in life
without those things i've never done the
work to figure that out and so writing
this book was the journey for me to
figure out how can i build a strong
foundation and when i say foundation i
mean like a safe place in my mind that
consists of pillars that do not connect
to all those external things and so when
i googled strong foundation the triangle
came up because it was structurally the
strongest shape with the strongest
foundation so i thought
that's it i need to be a triangle
you know when people talk about their
journey like their life journey people i
think they visualize like a person on a
path but there really are all these
parallel
people on these different paths going at
the same time that make up who you are
so when you look at where you are right
now after having written this book and
doing that sort of exploration into
yourself what do you think about the
journey that you were on before and
still are on but the journey before when
you didn't recognize those things it was
all about the hustle and all about the
work
yeah so i think that um
we don't have to be so all or nothing
and i think that's where i was before i
still really believe in working hard i
still really believe in hustling i i
enjoy
putting my 200 energy into things i've
i've learned that that's just how i am
as a human and i can't be another way
i've tried to be another way but i can't
and i used to resist that a lot because
i thought well if you're this then you
can't be mindful and you you can't take
breaks you have to be just this and i
think what i've learned is that progress
is in the middle it doesn't have to be
all or nothing you can work really
really hard as i have on this book as i
have on this press store and you can
still consider your mental health you
can still take that 10 minute break you
can still meditate every morning you can
still have fun um i won't lie the
hustling i did years ago i don't regret
it it has gotten me to where i am in my
career but i think where i am right now
is i believe in the intersection of
those two things a little more
can you tell me about when you said that
you have a hard times like processing
joy uh and success what is that what's
that about
yeah that's a great question because i
asked my therapist the exact same thing
i was like what's my deal what's my deal
here because i learned about myself that
i
never really take moments to think about
the things i've achieved you know i have
all these vision boards and i have all
of these things that are
have surpassed my expectations happen in
my life and then they are so fleeting
you know the next morning i'm like all
right what's next what's next i'm always
on this
never-ending race to accomplish more and
more and more without realizing that
like where i am is pretty great and my
therapist um explains to me very
eloquently that that has a lot to do
with just
cultural generational trauma of the fact
that in my upbringing perhaps things
weren't celebrated that much because my
parents being immigrant parents
did have to survive you know and so
energy wasn't spent so much towards
celebrating things but more towards just
saying oh that's something we don't have
to deal with let's put our energy
towards solving problems that are going
to head our way and so in my adult life
i find myself doing that i don't
celebrate things and instead i just
focus so much on dealing with things
that go wrong i've been trying to
unlearn that and trying to
relive cool things that have happened by
like telling them to a friend so i can
take a moment to be like and that was
actually really great and that felt
really great
how important is it to you
and like success you know success
whatever aside how important is it to
you to be sort of like the conduit in a
way for people that relate to those
ideas
i mean listen i
have come to terms with the fact that i
am a little bit of a disrupter i think i
used to resist that for a long time for
a long time i would be like why can't
you just
do the normal thing why can't you follow
the mold why can't you just why do you
have to dissect everything why do you
have to disrupt it i am now stepping
into that power and i am more than fine
being a disrupter of ideas and systems
and industries um i i don't
intentionally set out to be a leader
i've never done that i've never set out
to say
i have to be the first at this thing it
has turned out that i've been the first
in a lot of things because of my
upbringing um
but i'm just speaking from my lived
experience like you said and if people
find value in that that is great um but
i am just authentically a disruptor it's
not my it's not my
strategic agenda to do so
what is something now in 2022
that you know years ago you would have
been surprised
that actually just brings you joy now
oh
i'm kind of a crazy planned lady now
okay it's true i could not care about
plants years ago i could not keep a
single plant alive now every sunday and
for some of my plans on wednesdays i'm
like no
watering my plants and dusting my plants
and talking to my plants and i don't
care if that makes me crazy plant lady i
fully own that title but it brings me so
much joy
i
am on board for that i love like the
idea of the care and the nature that
goes yes my life might be falling apart
otherwise but this snake plant is gonna
be thriving this kentia palm tree is
gonna this zz plant is gonna be thriving
even if i'm falling apart
look i don't know man because from here
it doesn't look like things are falling
apart and i guess
they're not and you know what for
actually they're not i shouldn't even
joke about that i'm actually in a great
place right now
how has um stepping away from social
media actually had a hand in that
well i did it for a certain amount of
months during the pandemic i deleted
social media for about six seven months
and i learned a lot about myself in
those six seven months and more than
anything i learned how to adjust my
relationship with social media and that
required some distance from it i think i
definitely used to be the person that
would let any noise into my day i would
possibly scroll i started to believe
opinions were facts i started to believe
that this was the world just in this
phone i stopped uh remembering that
there's so much more out there and i
have social media on my phone again but
that's because my relationship like i
said has changed with it i now don't
believe it's the end-all be-all it's not
the main place i get my validation in
fact the best part of this entire press
tour thus far and i've done live events
i have gotten book sales i've done lots
of things on social media but the best
part of this entire press tour thus far
has been my mom calling me two days ago
and just so genuinely being like
i'm so proud of you
i'm sending you all of my love i hope
you have fun today and that is about
that's where i've been the best
best thing that has happened on this so
that i would not have had that
perspective uh years ago because i would
be like no the best thing is gonna be
what people tell me on social media and
they're gonna but i've just adjusted my
relationship with it
that's awesome you know i think that
we're not the same person we have the
same experience but you know they're
relatable things like when you are an
immigrant or you have immigrant parents
you know there is a bit of a through
line about sometimes talking about
personal things can be difficult right
now asking to be celebrated can be
difficult and you feel like a burden
sometimes right um you talked about
when you came out to your parents how
difficult that was
um and you've of course
come to terms with uh what that
conversation was like and what your
relationship was with them now what
would you tell
lily back then who was about to do that
about
what it was going to be like
um i think i would tell lily to give
people and i write a lot about a lot
about this in the book
i
this book has given me the power of
giving people context other people and
myself context which i don't think we do
very often these days because we're so
quick to label people conversations and
situations and i think that is a product
of the internet and social media we have
140 characters to label a situation take
it out of context and and say what we
want to say so that's now the reality i
don't think humans can operate like that
and so i would tell her to
understand and give credit to people's
lived experience and context because i
think back then i did expect instant
understanding instant celebration
um without
giving my parents the credit of they
were born in a different time and place
and they actually were very supportive
and were understanding they didn't did
they know every right word to say no but
how could they because this is the first
for them you know and so i would just go
back and tell lily to have a little more
grace and patience than i probably did
nice
um
your career has touched on so many
different things you're doing a lot more
now which is very very exciting i love
the idea of you
i love the projects the acting projects
that you have coming up um but when it
comes to youtube and the relationship
you've had with it over the decade or so
you know there aren't a lot of people
that have been in the position that
you've been in to be able to see the ups
and downs of not just you on the
platform but the platform itself
in this in 2022 what do you see as the
biggest sort of like
um challenges and also benefits of the
platform
well i think that it's a change a lot
since 2010 since i started youtube i
think
the benefit of it is also the challenge
i think my answer is the same to both of
those questions which is when i started
in 2010 no one really completely
understood it could be a career and it
could be as big and and creators could
have as big of businesses as they do
today and so there weren't as many
people on youtube doing what i was doing
um compared to now where there's a lot
of people creating content everyone is a
content creator in some capacity these
days um which is really great because
that means that
it's taken seriously and no one's
doubting the power of that platform no
one these days is saying youtube is
social media is gonna come and go no
one's saying that but i think even
though that's a pro the challenge is
very saturated now it's really hard to
um stand out because there are a lot
more people i don't know if i started
making youtube videos today if i would
be able to get the traction that i got
years ago that doesn't mean it's
impossible i think people just need to
be that much more authentic and creative
and um
i hope it just doesn't result in more
burnout but i think that is the pro and
the con i think it's the same answer
um as someone that's watched your career
ever since then it's always been
exciting to see what different things
that you've been doing and the different
sort of like
avenues you go down and success you find
it's nice to be able to be happy for you
being
finding clarity mental clarity which i i
love that for you
as far as your career goes what is
something that's very very exciting to
you that's coming up
oh
i mean i have a disney plus project
coming up it's called the muppets mayhem
i'm gonna start shooting at the end of
this month i'm super excited about that
because i'm a really big nerd when it
comes to production and i'm so excited
to see how they shoot some of this stuff
with them up it's like i'm reading these
scripts and i have no idea how they're
going to execute some of these ideas so
i'm really excited about that but i
think
more than anything i'm excited to just
follow the blueprint i wrote in this you
know i think this
everyone keeps asking me if i'll write
another book and my answer is i hope i
don't have to i hope that years from now
i can still follow what i wrote in this
book and so the biggest thing i'm
looking forward to is
the longevity of this mental clarity
more than any project more than any
shoot i have coming up i'm excited to
value myself more than those things
i love that hey thank you so much for
taking the time yeah thank you for
having me yeah dude so great always a
pleasure bye